après le grand louvre le gouvernement a
décidé de lancer le grand versailles
la nouvelle a été annoncée par catherine
trautmann le projet est ambitieux dix
ans de travaux pour mettre le château
normes de sécurité et pour améliorer
l'accueil des visiteurs présentation
avec béatrice casanova emmanuel hoog
singer louis xiv aurait apprécié la
nouvelle qui va être annoncés dans trois
semaines au conseil des ministres
le château de versailles et son parc
sont à l'ordre du jour pour une
rénovation modernisation mise en
sécurité
je vais présenter ce plan pluriannuel
avec un financement qui atteindra en
moyenne à peu près 150 millions de
francs par an nous faisons une première
étape en dans le budget 2001 avec
l'inscription de 100 millions de francs
après la fin des travaux du louvre nous
enchaînons sur versailles à la fois pour
sauvegarder ce patrimoine exceptionnel
qui est un patrimoine national mais en
même temps connu du monde entier et pour
favoriser l'accueil du public dans des
conditions optimales
au programme la remise à jour de tout le
système de détection l'électricité le
chauffage du château enfin la
réorganisation de l'accueil du public
un accueil jugé aujourd'hui obsolète
pour un monument qui reçoit chaque année
10 millions des visiteurs
on a un espace immense qui est quand
même assez négligés par les pouvoirs
publics depuis des décennies
si le champagne n'a été négligé et donc
c'est le moment de s'occuper de
versailles enfin le grand parc de
versailles soit 750 hectares de bois de
bosquets et des espaces verts va
s'offrir un véritable lifting lifting
qui n'avaient pas subi depuis maintenant
120 ans